in this video I'm speaking to two
different audiences one is the value
tainer the entrepreneur that follows
value tainment for content around
entrepreneurship the other one is an
individual he's a CEO of Twitter founder
of Twitter and square
billionaire recognized by MIT by
educators and by entrepreneurs around
the world Jack Dorsey Jack if you're
watching this video I have one intention
with this video I want to make sure the
world knows how valuable this brand is
but I also want to make sure this does
not become the next Yahoo in the next
myspace because one thing I could tell
you what happened with Yahoo interesting
stat on what happened with Yahoo
everybody Yahoo in February of 2008
during the most terrible time
financially we've experienced in America
the last 50 years Steve Ballmer from
Microsoft offered to buy Yahoo for forty
five billion dollars On February of oh
wait I believe and Yahoo said no in a
few years later yahoo ends up being
bought by Verizon for 4.8 billion
dollars just three months ago from 45
bill to 4.8 a very big difference and we
know what happened to myspace my
solution went out of business even I
thought myspace was a lot nicer cleaner
Facebook had nothing going on initially
Facebook took off myspace did and ended
up being going out of business and
somebody about it for 25 35 million I
think Justin Timberlake and few
investors so today in this video I'm
going to cover four different things one
is why the world needs Twitter simple as
that I'm gonna cover my end points with
you on why the world's needs Twitter 2
cannot be saved 3 why no one is buying
it some of the people that are
interested why no one is buying it and
then what Twitter needs to do as a
strategy moving forward to increase the
value of Twitter and I'm going to cover
with that with you at the end so you
want to watch this entire video so let
me get right into it on why I believe
this is a very very needed business and
company to be around and why don't why I
don't think there's nothing like it like
MySpace and Yahoo but it needs to be so
proper let me explain to why I love
Twitter think about it this way anytime
this is point number one anytime I see a
controversial topic that's taking place
Hillary Trump
bernie sanders director Comey stephen a
smith debate over certain athlete in car
car comes out there's some challenge
that happens with a new tesla are they
gonna be able to deliver any single
controversy social issue pro-life
pro-choice any major issue that have
earthquakes disasters in the middle east
it doesn't matter anything i want to
hear both sides of the argument I'll go
straight to Twitter you know why here's
why when's the last time you saw
somebody post fifty different messages
on Facebook in five minutes you don't
see that happening and the last time you
saw somebody doing that on Facebook what
did you call them that's weird what is
wrong with this obsessive person do you
know what happens if you send 50
messages on five minutes on Twitter they
just call you a Twitter user so nothing
wrong with that and somebody can be
watching that so if you want to hear
both arguments Twitter does a very good
job on that second thing for breaking
news I go to Twitter its immediate
breaking news and I want to hear what
the audience is saying about it breaking
news such-and-such password breaking
news this companies and the brakes of a
collapse breaking news I like some
breaking news sports breaking news trade
breaking news LeBron 11 breaking news
everything is breaking news that's the
second point with Twitter why we needed
three it's tracking trends doesn't
matter what word I'm looking for a lot
of people tend to go to Google I like to
go to Twitter because actively I want to
see are people talking about this word
who's using this word what are they
saying about this word what word is
trending twitter tells us what word is
trained from trending next one customer
service there's a lot of times where I
remember one time I was in Las Vegas and
I stayed at a hotel I was unhappy about
the service so I tweeted I am NOT happy
about how long it's taken for me to get
service at this hotel the fact that they
put me in a smoking room even though I
told them I'm non-smoking immediately I
got a response from another Hotel cæsar
that said we apologize about your
experience in Las Vegas here give us a
message we'd love to make up your
weekend and give you a show I went to
Cesar I stayed over there was a great
experience why customer service on
Twitter you get to find out what type of
customer service different companies
give on Twitter next following a
celebrity's a People magazine today is
done twitter has become the new People
magazine but Twitter needs to learn how
to sell it as a peep
magazine next short hundred forty
characters it's like reading a short
blog so if I'm busy I need to go
somewhere Twitter is a great place let
me see it I'm good I'm gone I got what I
needed to get outreach to people
interested in your product for instance
if you're selling a product that is
tailored to people who have many pets
and have many dogs and your product is
the fact that your dog is itching
themselves so much where all of a sudden
they're hurting themselves they're
bleeding they're you know because
they're itching themselves too much that
product can help the person that owns
the pet to say listen we don't want your
dog to go through this you search those
words you respond to that owner the
owner says try I'll try your product
they try your product and then now you
have a custom you would have never had
you can't do that on Facebook you can do
that on Twitter very powerful for small
businesses traffic to site marketing
branding there's just a lot of benefits
why Twitter needs to be around we just
need to see if Twitter wants to be fat
like this Twitter bird that I made here
instead of being skinnier and the
valuation keep getting smaller and
smaller and smaller so now let's talk
about some stats with Twitter some
numbers that all of us kind of need to
know about how big is Twitter what is
going on with Twitter right now Twitter
has roughly 3900 employees give or take
quarter 1 of 2016 they did roughly 600
minutes 600 million dollars last time
they turned on a prophet was q4 of 2015
their share is roughly right now $18 I
think in 13 that were at $69 $68 a share
that would work around 40 billion
dollars if they wanted to sell today the
rumor has it they're asking for 15 you
know some will probably be willing to
pay 5 to 8 billion today market says 8
to 12 billion but if they want to sell
today 5 to 8 billion dollars maybe
someone's going to be willing to pay for
that now here's what happens if that's
the case how come they're not selling
the following companies recently
publicly came out and they said they're
not interested obviously some of the
rumors came out they're trying to
protect Twitter but it's been on the
market for some time according to a lot
of different publications you read
Google and Disney on October 5th a say
they're not interested Apple said we
were never interested on October 6 and
Salesforce said on October 14 we're not
interested ok
not interested that's what they said so
a lot of times people are watching
Twitter and they saying what is Twitter
that's the biggest question so what is
Twitter it's Twitter more like MySpace
is a more like Facebook is it more like
Yahoo what is Twitter I don't know what
Twitter is it's Twitter a data
collecting company is it a news or what
is Twitter is its Twitter a news
organization is it becoming more of a
media type of a cup what is Twitter by
the way Jack by the way Twitter that's
actually not bad they needs to be
identified what Twitter is because most
people really don't know what Twitter is
and what Twitter is needed for once that
is identified the buyer is identified
and knowing how to pitch to the buyer is
identified just recently Twitter shut
down a vine and they didn't really
announce why they shut it down but they
shut it down probably a smart move they
did because you know Instagram snapchat
and they themselves with Twitter all the
old videos will stay online you just
cannot upload any new videos so while
you're looking at all this stuff and
you're looking at numbers you're
thinking man so what's gonna happen to
Twitter so it's really gonna go out of
business
I think if sometimes in a marketplace
when you put a house on the market for
price and you wait three months six
months people come see it but they make
you an offer way below or the house
doesn't sell 12 months later guess what
people start asking there's something
wrong with the house so there's a few
different things either there's some
some unsafe things that's going on the
community we don't know about there's
something really messed up in the house
physically that we don't know about when
we inspect maybe we'll find out maybe
the school and around the community just
got downgraded there was a shooting
score something we don't know about
maybe it's just overly priced
maybe it's just too optimistic maybe
it's just the area now is terrible
because crimes have gone up we don't
know what it is but there's a reason why
for 12 months that house hasn't sold
it's never no reason there's a reason
and you know what sometimes the best
thing to do sometimes the best thing to
do is to take your house off the market
come back fix it up and then bring you
back to the market 12 months later and
many times you may not even bring you
back to the market if you do it right I
think Twitter needs to go off the market
and Twitter needs to have a strategy
session and they need to put a team
together of people that sees it from a
different perspective a lot of times
person like Jack was running Twitter
when you're when you're doing well and
everybody is telling you how amazing you
are with your mind kind of like how I
did earlier the the difficulty we have
to live up to that expectation and when
we live to that expectation there's so
much pressure that we forget what it
meant to be open minded
we fully forget it we forget what it is
to be open minded and we start having
close it's like a general that's always
known for being the most incredible
general in the world and they become so
big and so good and then all of a sudden
they start thinking that everybody's
expecting them to be perfect instead
they stop asking one question what do
you think what do you think what do you
think and they start doing everything
them so they don't ask the team about
what do you think then they get caught
then they get hit because they're not on
a market place they've been distant they
get shot then they lose 2,000 soldiers
sometimes they lose the battle and
eventually at some times you lose the
war as well so I fully get where the
position jack is that and it's very
important to sit down and see if
somebody else's perspective on what can
happen because I fully believe not only
is this thing savable this thing can be
valued extremely high and there's one
buyer I guarantee you no one's even
thinking about this one buyer to sell to
and I'm telling you I am Telling You
this one group the buyer desperately
needs this desperately needs this
I'm not saying buy a little bit they
desperately needs to buy this brand
desperately need to buy this brand
so now stats are arguments to make for
Twitter what are some of the stats right
now in the marketplace we have seven and
a half billion people on earth say 7.2
billion people 2.1 billion consider
themselves active on social media what
is this number me to anything when when
coca-cola brought the CEO Roberto Gazeta
Cuban immigrant that came to coca-cola
at a time where Pepsi and Coke were
competing and Pepsi came out with that
one initiative that which tastes better
all that stuff and people were saying
Pepsi Pepsi Pepsi passed them up
Roberto who is Ed I came and said what a
small thinker why are you guys only
focused on beating Pepsi on coca-cola
let's see what people consume and he
asked what do people drink every day and
they said what I mean what do people
drink and they're we're coke company I
know but what do people drink every day
well they drink 16% is they drink 30%
water they drink this much milk they
drink this much
alcohol they have this they have that he
started buying companies like that
Dasani Minute Maid he started buying
those companies because he said I want
to get 100 percent of consumption of
whatever kind of liquid goes in here I
want that I think Twitter needs to start
looking at 2.1 billion people that are
actively on social media what ways can
we pull and what is their motivation to
want to use Twitter to increase them
benefit happiness joy whatever it is
that's the case on what to do with that
2.1 billion people now continuing the
one is one of the good news is with
twitter is the market that twitter is
doing very well in is 12 to 24 ages
which 32% is instagram twitter has 24%
of the marketplace during that age 12 to
24 facebook's 14% snapchats 13% tumbrils
4% Facebook's drop you don't meet a lot
of 14 year-olds talk and Facebook they
talk Twitter and Instagram more than
they do Facebook this is a good because
its future but that needs to be so
because 10 years from that Twitter has a
market that's gonna be aging at 24
they're still somewhat connected to
Facebook I'm 38 I'm emotionally
connected to Facebook because when I was
28 I was using Facebook's I've aged I've
grown up with Facebook but because I'm
in this you know space of social media I
need to learn how to adjust not
everybody does let's continue numbers
wise according to a CMO survey chief
marketing officer survey survey they
have said in the next 5 years companies
are gonna double more than double their
marketing budget from 11% to 24%
that they're going to use increase of
how much they can invest on social media
not TV not print social media what does
this mean a chunk of it can go here this
is an argument a chunk of it can go
there but you need to have a strategy on
how to get the chunk of it on there I
can go on with a couple other stats to
give you but I'm gonna get to the most
important stats here again all of this
is getting somewhere on a point that I
want to make 83% of to world's leaders
are on Twitter 83% of world's leaders
are in Twitter I will tell you right now
that if Donald Trump ends up becoming a
president if Donald Trump whether you
like him or not if Trump ends are
becoming a president whether he does or
not
he ended up becoming a Republican
nominee by beating out 16 other
candidates and then he ends up become
going against Hillary and it's able to
get it that close where he's got our
fighting chance to beat Hillary the
question would be what percentage of the
influence has to do with Twitter think
about it people always make fun of my
CEO he's so Twitter friendly and he goes
under - oh my gosh
take what is it's like a little kid and
he says look it's all about median
Twitter's a big platform Donald Trump
endorses Twitter jack whether you like
him or not it doesn't matter he endorses
the usage of Twitter and because he's a
better user of Twitter he's got a shot
at becoming a president what if the
influence of Twitter was 5% 10% 15% take
Twitter out you think he has the same
amount of opportunity to go viral I
don't know about that I think Twitter's
got a very big play with world leaders
there's something there for the argument
that I'm gonna make if I were to meet
with the board of Twitter on what I
would be doing next journalists make up
twenty four point six percent of
verified accounts on Twitter what does
that mean to Twitter well Twitter
there's leverage journalists need you if
you go out of business they're hurt that
is a very very big selling point because
journalists get a job by being having
followers and writing contents worth
reading and one of the places they go to
is Twitter Katy Perry's the biggest has
the most biggest total problem with 87
million people there you know Twitter
the biggest you know challenge that
Twitter gets is they got 310 million
active users Twitter does but they got
1.3 billion accounts that have been
created which is you know too many fake
accounts on Twitter way too many fake
accounts on Twitter that hurts the
reputation that Twitter needs to make a
move on that side so again I can't go on
with a lot of other stats here but let
me get into my four points with you
here's my four points with you and it's
very simple one we need to go do what
exactly Instagram did with their users
when they purged many of the fake
followers in 2014 and you saw Twitter
people who had a hundred thousand people
following them it went all the way down
to 17,000 many many people did that and
Instagram cleaned house and then all of
sudden Instagram was bought out by
Facebook Twitter needs to clean house it
shows authenticity
it shows transparency it shows
transparency to investors and users you
come out and say we purged we found that
we had three hundred and ninety eight
million fake accounts and we want to
change Twitter to a transparent Twitter
with cleaned house no more fake Twitter
accounts many numbers have changed it's
completely okay people are actually
gonna say wow lots of credibility on
Twitter they don't say today if I see
somebody on Twitter right now with six
hundred thousand followers I don't
believe it I don't believe it cuz I look
at them it's fake its fake I don't
believe it six hundred thousand
followers something needs to happen with
that part of Twitter second point I
would find a way to focus on businesses
listen businesses are gonna spend money
they're gonna spend money in business is
if you can show them a way to make money
if I spend ten million dollars with you
per month and you're gonna show me a way
to make fifteen million dollars on that
ten million I'm gonna keep doing fifteen
I'm a ten million dollars with you every
month it's purely math but show me that
my ten will turn into fifteen and
there's a way of doing that there is a
way of doing that but I would put a big
focus on businesses if I was Twitter a
big focus on businesses if I was Twitter
three you know I'd take a play out of a
Mark Zuckerberg playbook and I would
tell you what he did in 2007 I want to
say that it is March of 2007 he goes to
a Christmas party with a man named Dan
who me he meets Sheryl Sandberg there
for the first time I'm Sheryl at that
time I believe it's getting ready to go
to Washington Post to work for
Washington Post mark and and Sheryl
speak for a few minutes you know
whatever the timeline is they get along
they hit it off it's great they see each
other again at another world you know
political event has taken place and
again they hit it off it's like a
connection march of oh wait I want to
say I could be off by a month or two
March of oh wait
Mark Zuckerberg announces the new chief
operating officers who Sheryl Sandberg
so Sheryl Sandberg said of going to
Washington Post she goes to Facebook
when at a time where mark was being
crushed on quarterly conference call st.
mark when are you gonna make some
profits we want some profits and Mark
doesn't have answers and said we're
gonna figure it out we're gonna figure
it out we're gonna figure it out he
finally figures it out you bring Sheryl
Sandberg Sheryl Sandberg brings some of
our you know plays on what you have with
Google looks at Facebook everything
it's going on we need to change this
this this this this phone Facebook takes
off
Facebook's right now worked a few
hundred marks worth 60 Cheryl's what one
and a half give or take and if she would
have gone to Washington Post this would
have never happened but she came to
Facebook so who gets credit for the
turnaround on Facebook Sheryl or mark I
think it's marked because mark went
actively recruiting for talent like
Sheryl to bring in and then Cheryl gets
the credit for coming through making a
play happen and she wins and history
books are gonna favor Sheryl Sandberg
when the history books of Facebook are
written later on against their what
happened for Facebook to be turned
around her name will be on there she is
a hall-of-famer on Facebook forever to
come Jack needs to be doing the same
thing I would be actively recruiting
killers in a marketplace to become
heroes when AIG was almost going out of
business they called one man one man
they called the man was a former CEO of
MetLife he had three years to live I met
this guy many many times I've had dinner
with this man his name was Bob ben-moshe
Bob Mann Moshe was at his vineyard in
Croatia Dubrovnik which is a beautiful
place
they call him they say hey we need you
to come and see if you can do anything
with AIG he says look I'm on my deathbed
I got three more years to live I'm
enjoying myself I'm having fun here no
way in the world but it was sold as you
could be possibly the person that's
saved one of the biggest companies in
the world and the history books are
gonna talk about you as the CEO that
turned everything around for AIG he
thought about it talked to his son made
some choices came back makes a phone
call to the government gets the money
brings on David Herzog promotes him from
American General David becomes the CFO
David's brain is an incredible brain
I've had dinner with David they start
working with the government properly
stop bullying US government we gonna pay
you back he takes the comment company
makes the decision a few things they
need to do they bar 183 billion few
years later he gives 183 billion back
plus twenty three billion dollars in
interest something GM still hasn't done
and the public says AIG we forgive you
he saves AIG insurance everything stays
on the books job stays on the books
government money's given back taxpayers
got their money back
badam oh she just died last this year
2016 February he just said when we were
doing our convention on that Friday
night ceremony he died that night I
think was in January
late January first week of February he
passes away and anybody who ever writes
any business books and AIG is written
Bobby Moi's his name's gonna be there
Jack can go get somebody to become a
hero for a company like this in history
books will favor them just like mark got
sheryl sandberg
and how many other ideas i have three
other ideas that are very very unique
ideas that i believe they're proven i
believe it's gonna work because both
parties will need to do these things
three ideas and have one idea on who we
need to go to to sell if i was to sit
down with jack dorsey and talk to him
and his team from twitter i would be
more than happy to do that because for
me my brain I look at businesses and I
like what things need to be around
especially businesses that I use I use
Twitter Twitter needs to stick around
this is a product that needs to stick
around and if I can find a way to
contribute towards it I'd love to do it
so with that being said value Tanner's
couple of things if you agree with any
of the video I need you to tweet Jack
his Twitter account it's literally jack
then it's let's put the image so people
know it's Jack and tweet jack and say
Jack watch this entire video and meet
with Pat watch this entire video meet
with Pat and Jack if you watch this
entire video it's very easy to get ahold
of you can find me all over social media
if we hear from you great if we don't
hear from you I wish you the best of
luck I truly hope you figure out ways to
make it happen if we can contribute in a
way and help to go to another level I'll
be more than happy to meet with you and
give you some feedback on what we can do
with Twitter to get a back up and have
this one massive organization that is
desperately desperately interested in
this product desperately interested in
this product that you happen B happen to
be the CEO of Twitter so with that being
said folks if you got any thoughts any
opinions about Twitter comment on the
bottom if you would like to see Twitter
make certain adjustments and improve to
not be the next myspace and Yahoo also
comment on the bottom and if you haven't
subscribed to the channel click right
here to subscribe as well take everybody
bye-bye
you